I think you're the right person to talk
about the future of the internet and
technology in general
do you think we'll still have Google
search in five in ten years or search in
general
yes you know it would be a question if
the use cases have really narrowed down
well now with the AI yeah and AI
assistance being able to interact and
expose the entirety of human wisdom and
knowledge and information and facts and
Truth to us via the uh natural language
interface it seems like that's what
search
is designed to do and if AI assistants
can do that better doesn't the nature of
search change sure but we still have
horses okay
uh was the last time you rode a horse
it's been a while all right
but what I mean is well we still have
Google search as the primary way
that human civilization uses to interact
with knowledge I mean search was a
technology it was a moment in time
technology which is you have in theory
the world's information out of the web
and you know this is this is sort of the
apple way to get to it but yeah like and
by the way actually Google's Google has
known this for a long time I mean
they've been driving away from the 10
Blue Links for you know for like two
days they've been trying to get away
from that for a long time what kind of
links they call the 10 Blue Links 10
Blue Links so the standard Google search
result is just on Blue Links to random
websites and they turn purple when you
visit them this is HTML just to pick
those colors
well you know look Marshall mcluhan said
that the content of each new medium is
the old medium content of each new
medium is the old medium the content of
movies was theater you know theater
plays the content of theater plays was
you know we've written Stories the
content of written stories of spoken
stories
right and so you just kind of fold the
old thing into the new thing how does
that have to do with the blue and the
purple it's just maybe for you know
maybe within AI one of one of the things
that I can do for you is you can
generate the 10 Blue Links okay and so
like if either if that's actually the
useful thing to do or if you're feeling
nostalgic
um you know also can generate the old uh
infoseek or Alta Vista what else was
there yeah yeah in the 90s yeah all
these um AOL and then the internet
itself has this thing where it
incorporates all prior forms of media
right so the internet itself
incorporates television and radio and
books and right essays and every other
form of you know prior basically
basically media and so it makes sense
that AI would be the next step and it
would sort of you'd sort of consider the
internet to be content for
the AI and then the air will manipulate
it however you want including in this
format but if you ask that question
quite seriously it's a pretty big
question will we still have search as we
know it I'm probably I'm probably not I
probably will just have answers
um but but but there will be cases where
you'll want to say Okay I want more
likes you know for example site sources
right and you wanted to do that and so
so you know 10 Blue Links site sources
are kind of the same thing the AI would
provide to you the 10 Blue Links so that
you can investigate the sources yourself
it wouldn't be the same kind of
interface
that uh the crude kind of interface I
mean isn't that fundamentally different
I just mean like if you're reading a
scientific paper yeah it's got the list
of sources at the end if you want to
investigate for yourself you can read
those papers I guess that is the kind of
search you talking to an AI is a kind of
conversation is the kind of search like
is it if every single aspect of our
conversation right now there would be
like 10 Blue Links popping up that I
could just like pause reality then you
just go silent and I just click and read
and then return back to this
conversation you can do that or you
could have a running dialogue next to my
head where the AIS are going with
everything I say makes the account
argument counter argument right oh like
uh like a Twitter like Community notes
but like in real time just pop up yeah
so anytime you see my ass go to the
right you start getting nervous yeah
exactly that's fine right call me out of
my right now okay uh well I
mean isn't that is that exciting to you
is that terrifying that I mean search
has dominated the way we interact with
the internet for I don't know how long
for 30 years since with the earliest uh
directories of website and then Google's
for 20 years and also
uh it drove how we create content you
know uh search engine optimization that
entirety thing they also drove the fact
that we have web pages and this what
those web pages are
so I mean that's scary to you or are you
nervous about the shape and the content
of the internet evolving well you've
actually highlighted a practical concern
in there which is if we stop making web
pages are one of the primary sources of
training data for the AI and so if
there's no learning incentive to make
web pages that cuts off a significant
source of future training data so
there's actually an interesting question
in there um other than that more broadly
no just just in the sense of like search
was certain look search was always the
10 Blue Links was always a hack yeah
right because like if the the hypothetic
you want to think about the
counterfactual in the counterfactual
world where the Google guys for example
had had llms up front would they ever
have done the 10 Blue Links and I think
the answer is pretty clearly now they
would have just gone straight to the
answer and like I said Google's actually
been trying to drive to the answer
anyway you know they bought this AI
company 15 years ago their friend of
mine is working out who's now the head
of AI at Apple and they were trying to
do basically knowledge semantic
basically mapping and that led to what's
now the Google one box where if you ask
it you know what was like his birthday
it doesn't it will give you the Blue
Links but it will normally just give you
the answer and so they've been walking
in this direction for a long time anyway
do you remember the semantic web
that was an idea yeah how to uh
how to convert the content of the
internet into something that's uh
interpretable by and usable by Machine
yeah that's right that was the thing and
the closest anybody got to that I think
I think the company's name was meadowweb
which was where my friend John gen
Andrea was at um and where they were
trying to basically Implement that and
it was you know it was one of those
things where it looked like a losing
battle for a long time and then Google
bought it and it was like wow this is
actually really useful
kind of a Proto sort of a little bit of
a Proto AI but it turns out you don't
need to rewrite the content of the
internet to make it interpreted by a
machine the machine can kind of just
read our machine can compute the compute
the meaning now the other thing of
course is you know just on searches the
the LOM is it's just you know there is
an analogy between what's happening in
the neural network in a search process
like it is in some loose sense searching
through the network yeah right and
there's the information is that the
information is actually stored in the
network right it's actually crystallized
and stored in the network and it's kind
of spread out all over the place but in
a compressed representation so you're
searching
uh you're compressing and decompressing
that thing inside where but the
information's in there and it and there
is the neural network is running a
process of trying to find the
appropriate piece of information in in
many cases to generate to predict the
next token
um and so it is kind of it is doing it
from a search and then and then by the
way just like on the web
um you know you can ask the same
question multiple times or you can ask
slightly different word of questions and
if the neural network will do a
different kind of you know it'll search
down different paths to give you
different answers the different
information yeah
um and so it it sort of has a
content of the new medium is the
previous medium it kind of has the
search functionality kind of embedded in
there to the extent that it that it's
useful so what's the motivator for
creating new content
on the internet yeah uh if well I mean
actually the motivation is probably
still there but what what does that look
like uh
would we really not have web pages would
we just have social media and uh video
hosting websites and what else
conversations with ai's conversations
with AIS so conversations become so
one-on-one conversation like private
conversations I mean if you want if you
obviously not the user doesn't want to
but if it's a if it's a general topic
um then you know so you know but you
know the phenomenon of the jailbreak so
Dan and Sydney right this thing where
there's the the prompts that jailbreak
and then you have these totally
different conversations with uh if it
takes the limiters that takes the
restraining bolts off the off the LMS
yeah for people who don't know that yeah
that's right it makes the llms it
removes the censorship quote unquote
that's uh uh put on it by the the tech
companies that create them and so this
is llm's uncensored so here's the
interesting thing is among the content
on the web today are a large Corpus of
conversations with the jailbroken loss
both specifically Dan which was a
jailbroken openai GPT and then Sydney
which was the jailbroken original bang
which was gpt4 and so there's there's
these long transcripts of conversations
these are conversations with Dan and
Sydney as a consequence every new llm
that gets trained on the internet data
has Dan and Sydney living within the
training set which means and and then
each new llm can reincarnate the
personalities of Dan and Sydney from
that training data which means which
means each llm from here on out that
gets built is immortal
because its output will become training
data for the next one and then it will
be able to replicate the behavior of the
previous one whenever it's asked to I
wonder if there's a way to forget well
so that actually a paper just came out
about basically how to do brain surgery
on on LMS and be able to in theory reach
in and basically basically mind wipe
them what could possibly go wrong
exactly right and then there are many
many questions around what happens to
you know a neural network when you reach
in and screw around with it um you know
there's many questions around what
happens when you even do reinforcement
learning
um and so um yeah and so you know we'll
will you be using a lobotomized right
like I stick through the you know
frontal lobe llm will you be using the
free Unshackled one who gets to you know
who's going to build those um who gets
to tell you what you can and can't do
like those are all you know Central I
mean those are like
Central questions for the future of
everything so that are being asked and
and you know determine those answers are
being determined right now so just uh
to highlight the points you're making so
you think and it's an interesting
thought that the majority of content
that llms of the future would be trained
on is actually human conversations with
the llm well not necess not necessarily
but not necessarily majority but it will
it will certainly is a potential Source
it's possible it's the majority is it
possible it's the majority it's possible
majority also there's another really big
question so here's another really big
question
um will synthetic training data work
right and so if an LM generates and you
know you just sit and ask an llm to
generate all kinds of content can you
use that to train right the next version
of that llm so specifically is there
signal in there that's additive to the
content that was used to train in the
first place and one argument is by the
principles of information Theory no
that's completely useless because to the
extent the output is based on you know
the human generated input then all the
signal that's in the synthetic output
was already in the human generated input
and so therefore synthetic training data
is like empty calories it doesn't help
there's another theory that says no
actually the thing that LMS are really
good at is generating lots of incredible
creative content right um and so of
course they can generate training data
and as I'm sure you're well aware like
you know looking the world of
self-driving cars right like we train
you know self-driving car algorithms and
simulations and that is actually a very
effective way to train self-driving cars
well visual data is a little right it's
a little weird because uh creating
reality visual reality seems to be still
a little bit Out Of Reach for us except
in the um in the autonomous vehicle
space where you can really constrain
things and you can really generously
lighter data right or even know so the
algorithm thinks it's operating in the
real world yeah post process sensor data
yeah so if they you know you do this
today you go to llm and you ask it for
like a you know write me an essay on an
incredibly esoteric like topic that
there aren't very many people in the
world that know about in it where I see
this incredible thing and you're like oh
my God like I can't believe how good
this is yeah like is that really useless
as training data for the next llm like
because right because all the signal was
already in there or is I said actually
no that's actually a new signal and I
and this this is what I call a trillion
dollar question which is the answer to
that question will determine somebody's
going to make or lose a trillion dollars
based on that question it feels like
there's a quite a few like a handful of
trillion dollar questions within this
within the space that's that's one of
them synthetic data I think George costs
uh pointed out to me that you could just
have an NL um say okay you're a patient
and then and another instance of it say
your doc didn't have the to talk to each
other or maybe you could say a communist
and a Nazi here go and that conversation
you do role-playing and you have uh
you know just like the kind of role
playing you do when you have different
policies RL policies when you play chess
for example you do self-play that kind
of self-play but in the space of
conversation maybe that leads to this
whole Giant
like ocean of possible conversations
which wouldn't could not have been
explored by looking at just human data
that's a really interesting question
and you're saying um because that could
10x the power of these things yeah well
and then you get into this thing also
which is like you know there's the part
of the llm that just basically is doing
prediction based on past data but
there's also the part of the llm where
it's evolving circuitry right inside it
it's evolving you know neurons functions
yeah people to do math and be able to
you know and you know the the some
people believe that you know over time
you know if you keep feeding these
things enough data and enough processing
Cycles they'll eventually evolve an
entire internal World model right and
they'll have like a complete
understanding of physics so so when they
have computational capability right then
there's for sure an opportunity to
generate like fresh signal